over the last couple of years we've seen
a lot of innovations with alarm clocks
that wake you up with different kinds of
lights and sounds and vibrations but
this is an alarm clock that wakes you up
with smell this is the olfactory alarm
clock from French startup sensor wake
which is currently part of a Google
France incubator it's an alarm clock
that wakes you up with smell using these
little pods these little pods contain
scents developed by a French perfume
house specifically meant to stimulate
your senses and wake you up within two
minutes if that doesn't happen you will
get a back up beat so you don't miss
that morning meeting their scents like
chocolate butter toast these perfume
pods cost $10 for a two pack and a sort
of a razor blade business model you buy
them in each pod last to 30 days so
you're effectively paying five dollars a
month to wake up to the smell of fresh
toast it first appeared on Kickstarter
last summer and will start hitting
Kickstarter backers this May with units
available for retail by the end of the
summer